foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong the weekly showcase where we talk
about movies in
many films we decide whether the Tomato
Meter got it right here at Rotten
Tomatoes my name is Mark Ellis I am
usually joined by my wonderful co-host
Jacqueline Coley and usually if she's
not here I'll say something glowing Lego
She's On Assignment she's working on a
project I bet Jacqueline is at home
playing video games and that is so well
deserved because she just came off the
award season run where she's covering
everything Coast to Coast
internationally we had the Oscars
recently and so Jacqueline Coley
deserving of her respite play those
video games probably playing The Last of
Us given what everybody's watching on TV
right now so we have some ringers that
we brought in to make up for the loss of
Miss Coley first and foremost my good
buddy comedian actor you can catch him
weekly on the show capes and cows Mr
Winston Marshall how are you bud I'm
good man I'm good I'm good it's my first
time in the studio yeah this is this is
fun this is amazing call up to the show
absolutely I mean the whole time I've
had the show my like dirty office it's
like that you know I mean it's nice to
be in like a curated properly lit like
sounding without the Echo and the
construction in the background just
chef's kiss it was always fun having you
in like virtually though because you
almost had the green screen take up your
entire shop but there's always a part
where you're like is that Winston's bed
it's around your bed I'm like I don't
know what Winston's doing behind closed
doors but it seems like he's got a
thriving career on various websites that
was the problem is that like there's
when you live in a studio apartment like
what do you what do you do like how do
you hide all of that you kind of can't
so then people are like oh and I'm like
no I swear to God I was about this year
at the superstore that's not what that's
not what this was I swear on Jesus you
have to embrace the studio and also
making her debut on Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong in studio or otherwise it is one
of my dear friends and she has so much
going on right now she's a shining
example of hard work paying off that's
actually the name of her short film that
she stars and directed and is coming out
soon one shining example also in
theaters later on in March we have malum
it's getting a wide theatrical release
and it stars Miss Clark wolf welcome to
the show thank you so much for having me
I'm so happy to be here
she did find a way to wedge some horror
into this episode where we're talking
about Mr Keanu Reeves his incredible
body of work he's had this odd career
where we always loved him but we weren't
really sure if he was a good actor or we
just liked him he's he Charming can he
actually pull off a wide variety of
roles I think after watching his
Resurgence with the John Wick movies and
other things we can safely say we're
still not really sure but that's why we
love talking Keanu Reeves movies and so
what we did today is we picked one movie
each that's rotten on the Tomato Meter
and we're going to defend that with
Vigor or we're going to say hey it's
right on the Tomato Meter but it's still
too high it's gonna be an interesting
debate here so we have a couple things I
want to point out editorial wise on the
website rottentomatoes.com you can check
out the 30 essential football movies
that might factor into one of our picks
here today and we also have all the
Keanu Reeves movies ranked and here is
what is nuts about our choices our
choices are sequential on the list of
all the Keanu movies ranked so starting
off with number 41 out of his 57 flicks
in the Tomato Meter is Clark Wolf's pick
knock so Winston Marshall I'm just going
to ask you not Clark
is knock knock on the Tomato Meter
currently at 37 rotten did Rotten
Tomatoes get it right or wrong they got
it wrong okay it should be in one
okay is there a zero percent or number
one one percent oh boy okay look I'll
give you ten it could have ten percent
and that's because I love the premise
and Clark the one gift that I have to
say thank you for that might be the
sexiest three-person cast of all time I
mean you're welcome that's exactly where
it stops I didn't know that editor
armist had a sister a time in her life
where she couldn't act either because
because all of a sudden I was like oh so
y'all just live in a fantasy land where
none of this makes any logical sense and
you clearly have no idea that you live
in a real world scenario what so it like
I don't have a problem with the idea of
like the home invasion and all that but
the acting was so bad all right well be
careful because Clark is a she's a
master of horror as far as filmmaking
and just being a fan goes and so I feel
like Clark might have some pushback as
to why the acting was the way it was in
that movie but now we turn it over to
miss wolf for Winston selection which is
the tearjerker from 2001 Hardball 41
rotten Clark wolf did Rotten Tomatoes
get that wrong I think so I think so I
think with all of our picks today uh the
the theme I think is going to be the
type of movie we are in yes and I think
that there is something too embracing
knowing what movie you're in and so I
think with a very tear-jerker sweet you
know heartfelt story uh like Hardball I
think that everybody is showing up for
that movie same with The Replacements
thank you which is my movie at a perfect
transition there because The
Replacements everybody definitely knew
what movie they were in when The
Replacements came out from Keanu Reeves
to Gene Hackman and everyone else The
Replacements the wonderful football
movie The based on a true story very
Loosely based on a true story of the
1987 Washington football team now known
as the commanders it's 41 rotten Winston
despite your affiliation with another
team in the NFC East what do you think
about the 41 for The Replacements did
Rotten Tomatoes Get It Wrong absolutely
got it wrong this should be at like an
80. oh thanks it is it is re-watching it
for this it's very cheesy but it's not
let's not pretend like there isn't camp
in there the cheerleader like audition
scenes uh
that was a
57-42 that is that 20 yards how many
yards it is like it just it has all
these elements that are you look back
you're like this is very much a 2000
movie sure sure but the heart like you
said in this film uh Clark was talking
about that earlier with Hardball there's
so much heart in it there's so many like
great lessons because even though on the
one hand looking at the NFL now
I agree that the players should get as
much money as they can considering
they're putting their bodies on the line
what the owners are taking all that kind
of stuff at the same time it was showing
hey these regular Joe's are out here in
these streets and they deserve that
recognition as well they deserve that
chance I just love everything this movie
has to give yeah it felt like they were
playing for their city which is our
nation's capital uh Clark wolf 41 rotten
for The Replacements how does that
tomato major score hit you I I agree
with Winston I think it should be much
higher I think for what this movie is
especially but this cast is so good yes
like they are now again uh we are
painting with a broad Strokes 2000s
brushes so that is your little
disclaimer and asterisks but that said
everybody is very good and I uh I've
lost touch with him but I was friendly
with Orlando Jones for a while and he to
me stood out he's so good in this movie
he is a star and he's entertaining and
you know I love a dance sequence and I
get two of them in this room we got a
prison dance sequence which I don't know
has been on screen since Jailhouse Rock
nothing has made me happier than seeing
black people and white people and one
Japanese guy come together and so poorly
do the Electric Slide but every time I'm
in there with them
so we're
telling of him always but also the John
Wick franchise gets a new chapter March
24th John Wick chapter four coming out
I've gotten a chance to see the movie I
think it's currently 87 percent on the
Tomato Meter and it might not be high
enough man the the one word I'm telling
everybody I'm not gonna ruin anything
nunchucks
that sense is that guy in the sewer who
looks like a turtle named Michelangelo
have I seen nunchucks on screen this
well done wow so again we got all the
piano movies right you can check that
out as well as the 30 essential football
movies on rottentomatoes.com before we
get into movie talking defending our
choices we're going to turn it over to
our buddy Tim Ryan he's our expert
review curation manager here at Rotten
Tomatoes and his job is to tell us what
the critics were saying about these
three films at the time of their release
as Clark wolf would say a very broad
2000s brush it's all yours Tim
with him is there a celebrity more
beloved than Keanu Reeves maybe that's a
stretch but is there a celebrity that
makes everyone go they seem like they're
probably pretty cool besides Keanu
Reeves maybe Dolly Parton and Snoop but
it's a pretty small club in his public
Persona at least Keanu Reeves is
somebody who seems to wear his movie
star status lightly but that almost
undersells the fact that he's also
carved out one of the most distinctive
bodies of work of any actor of his
generation from big budget action films
to small in detromedies
so even if his movies aren't all
critical Raves and even if he's taken
some knocks from reviewers over the
years you have to give him credit for a
willingness to try almost anything so
with that in mind here's what the
critics had to say about three of those
less well-reviewed films The
Replacements Hardball and knock knock
The Replacements from 2000 is rotten at
41 on the Tomato Meter with 108 reviews
and it has a 66 audience score
Hardball from 2001 is rotten at 41 with
115 reviews and it has a 70 audience
score
and knock knock from 2015 is rotten at
37 with 75 reviews and it has a 19
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a rotten review for knock
knock Chris Knight of Canada's national
post wrote even fans of Ross past work
will probably be disappointed by the
relative lack of Gore in this one which
suggests a mix of horror and Thriller
but quickly settles into more of the
latter but give Reeves full marks for
committing to his role however in a
fresh review for Hardball Renee
Rodriguez at the Miami Herald wrote
Reeves hits a wide variety of emotional
notes here from Conor's comic
bethuddlement on the field to his
mounting desperation as he Dodges
increasingly impatient lone sharks he
fares well too in his scenes opposite
Diane Lane so that's a couple of Keanu
Reeves movies let's kick it back to Mark
who knows that all we are is Dust in the
Wind dudes
oh man that's a great great outro Tim
and back to us here talking about uh our
three Keanu Reeves movies but I will
give a shout out to again my beloved
co-host Jacqueline Coley probably
playing a video game right now she loves
Constantine so I'm gonna put that out
there Constantine is that rotten it is
rotten what and you just you hear
Jacqueline is a voice of the people I
think it's like high 40s it's like 49 or
something like that so that was my first
picture was like I was like oh can I do
Constantine and like we've just we've
spent a lot of time already okay fine
fine that's fine it's like all these
movies are like countries in the board
game of Risk and you're like oh can I
just see what's going on with Oscar
bigger than like Austria has been it's
it's been claimed it's done okay you
gotta go somewhere else that's what
we're about to do is we transition into
movie talk
yeah Constantine is an interesting movie
sort of to kick off with just in terms
of the discrepancy between the Tomato
Meter and the verified audience score
because a lot of these Keanu Reeves
movies that are rotten like Constantine
46 of the Tomato Meter all the way up to
72 percent with the audience same can be
said for two of the three films that
we're talking about here today where the
audience score dramatically improves
another film the audience score
mysteriously drops precipitously in
terms of when you look at the Tomato
Meter but let's just kick this off Clark
with why do we love Keanu Reeves so much
going all the way back to the first time
you were aware of this human who is in
movies I think he's just uh so sincere
he has such a sincerity and like a very
authentic an authenticity about him to
the point where I think if people are
being critical of him as an actor that
might be where it comes from is he's so
much himself that maybe we have a hard
time or he has our hard time sort of
breaking out and stepping outside of
that he's his own Vibe yes exactly and
but I will say you know some of these
movies and we'll talk about it but there
are certain movies here where I'm like
this fits him better or or maybe this
doesn't fit him as well and that's
that's I think gonna that's been the
Journey of his his career as a movie
star which is a thing unto itself I'm
curious if for both y'all's take on just
the first time that you were aware of
like was there a movie that was coming
out and you're like who's that guy
that's a great question I was doing that
mental gymnastics in my head
um I think it's the Matrix and it's just
from the standpoint of like I was born
in 87 so okay I watched the stuff that I
watched so like Ninja Turtles on repeat
uh the Power Rangers movie on repeat
like I didn't really stray outside of
the things that I so it wasn't until
around when I became a teenager that I
started to become more broadly aware of
like movies movie stars Etc and I
remember everybody being like this major
movie's Gonna Be Wild I was like what is
that and then once I saw it I was like
yo that dude's really good and then
remember the next year seeing The
Replacements and being like well I love
Neo and neat and that you know Matrix
thing he's killing it as a quarterback
and then he turned around and did
Hardball which is probably one of my
favorite sports movies of all time yeah
I think a lot of people agree with that
too even if it's such an emotional
Powerhouse and what a wild pit packs
towards the end that we'll talk about
but yeah I think a lot of people even if
they can't watch the end every time they
watch it it is such a rewatchable movie
for that that Sports kind of juice you
get for me it was Point Break when it
was coming out it's funny because I'm
seven years older than you and so we're
going back from the Matrix almost seven
years I think Point Break was 91 but I
remember coming out and the first push I
was like Keanu Reeve Reed is he
Christopher Reeves kid I thought it was
Christopher Reeve's son and I'm like man
this Reeve bloodline is just killing you
got Superman they got this guy because
he was acting with Patrick Swayze and I
was way too young to like go see and buy
a ticket for Point Break right I don't
know if I convinced my mom to dropped me
off at the theater for that movie if she
let me do it because Patrick Swayze big
in our household let's just say Mom fan
of the sways okay so I don't know if I
was allowed to see that but I definitely
remember renting it and then maybe the
next year at most speed came out and I
was like ah there's the guy again and
speed was a great action movie it's it's
actually I think his second highest on
the Tomato Meter speed is you know
what's interesting is that I actually
saw speed two first uh oh so like and I
liked speed too because I didn't have
context to see the first one and see oh
this fell a lot so like for me that's
one of those guilty pleasure everybody
goes this is trash and I'm like no it's
not and then I re-watched them about a
year ago oh my God this is awful I love
Winston's perspective where he's
watching the first speed and he's like I
don't know if Keanu can keep up with
chasing Patrick because man was he
really just going all out on that boat I
love that you're bringing up uh you
bring up Point Break though because I
think to the the essence of the question
of Keanu I grew up up on Bill and Ted
and that's a great that's probably
that's definitely the first time I saw
him now that I think about it that's why
Clark that's why that's why she's the
best she knows my history better than I
know you're welcome you're welcome but I
I was I was thinking about it and it's
like Bill and Ted is like this like yeah
dude part you know bro kind of thing
which is so uh charming and fits him so
well and then we get into the surfing
and we get into Point Break I think and
then Keanu is of that age where he's had
box office success and he's a heartthrob
so he's having to break out of this sort
of surfer dude kind of thing and and it
it's got to be a tall order if that's
where the world knows you have I always
think of Bram Stoker's Dracula yes so
that movie that should be talked about a
movie that needs to be discussed at all
times for reasons
um but you know I think that that is not
keanu's best performance but I don't
think that's his fault because he should
not have been in that movie that is not
you know what I'm saying like I think
that is miscasting and but I understand
why he was in that movie because he was
hot and sexy you know big and young and
all these things so it's just a it's
just he just is such an interesting uh
figure to place in uh opportunity for
success is that how you see Bram service
Dracula with him playing Jonathan Harker
in it because like the one thing you
can't take away from him in that movie
and I don't think he's good in the movie
is that he's he's really giving it his
life he is he's doing everything he can
but to quote one of your former football
coaches Bill Parcells saying like if I'm
gonna cook the meal you got to let me
shop for the groceries I almost feel
like Francis Ford Coppa was like okay I
got this cast I got to hand pick some of
them and then maybe the studio maybe
somebody else just said hey can you put
this kid is really hot right now in the
movie too to appeal to younger folks is
that your read on it yeah that that I
could yes yes that makes that actually
is a very good description of it is that
uh let me pick it honestly like The
Replacements liter literally like you're
gonna let me hand pick all the people
and then the minute Bartel Martel
martel's the quarterback other
quarterback the high paid pretty boy the
Brady
uh as soon as he crosses the picket line
it's like uh well no he's the owner
saying no he's in and he's like no no no
no no no no no you told me I could pick
my people I I want Falco and you're like
I don't care you're putting it that's
kind of what that felt like a little
which is why one of the many reasons why
I love The Replacements so much and we
can kick off this conversation about
these three movies chronologically and
The Replacements is first in 2000
followed by Hardball in 2001 then knock
knock in 2015. I believe so The
Replacements I mean I remember coming
out and my family being very excited
about this movie because it is based on
Washington and that's like my family's
just it's in our blood rooting for that
football team and it was a very loose
true story that I'll go over very
quickly 1987 the year that we ended up
winning the Super Bowl with Doug
Williams as our quarterback in MVP That
season was strike shortened because you
had one game that was missed because the
players went on strike and so when they
were on the picket line the owner said
well this could last though like it
could last a month we don't know how
long let's get replacement players in
there instead so some teams are like oh
we're getting replacement players do we
even like how do we find this but Joe
Gibbs the coach of Washington is like
I'm gonna take advantage of the hand on
dealt and I'm gonna find the best
players and if we're only playing for
one week if we're playing for three
weeks we're gonna win our games three
weeks is how long the replacement
players were playing in the NFL Joe
gibbs's team won all three as Washington
including a big Monday night showdown in
Dallas against the Cowboys when Cowboys
stars like Danny White had crossed the
picket line and we still beat the
Cowboys so it's like this big thing in
history so the movie very very many
Liberties taken with that lore but you
also have Gene Hackman as this coach
who's looking to come back Shane Falco
you talk about Keanu Reeves playing
former college quarterbacks like he did
in Point Break gets to do that again as
Shane Falco who's just down and out
living on a boat very simple life trying
to hold his dreams at Bay because it
doesn't seem like they're going to come
through then he gets this opportunity
and we love movie where a guy gets an
opportunity as an underdog and knocks it
out of the stadium I gotta ask you a
question because you just answered it
but I need to just verify that you're
not just pulling my leg you're telling
me that they legitimately put amateur
football players and still beat the
Dallas Cowboys in like real life yeah
this is the worst day of my life why do
you think I invited you on the show you
were a horrible person because you
missed to me but clearly it was just a
troll not saying I'm a good guy but I
brought your Washington commanders gear
you let me borrow so I can shoot that
Tick Tock I'm gonna burn it now you're
not getting it back well you know what
whatever makes Dan Snyder just stay up
at night so you do you do the burning
and Effigy all you want uh Clark when
you watch The Replacements what is it
about the movie for you that says wait a
minute wait the Tomato Meter got this
wrong this is a fresh movie first of all
I think that Keanu is really speaking of
casting is really well cast in this in
that he's a movie star
um but he feels so relatable and I think
that in the character of Shane Falco
it's like this guy who was a star who
had a bad day and is somebody special
but has been sort of pushed to you know
out of the spotlight so I could totally
I feel like he just inhabits that energy
of somebody you can't take your eyes off
of you know that they are they are
someone special and yet they're living
this humble modest kind of reserved life
and so so it felt it fit him like I I
will get to Hardball in a second but I
will say his relationship with those
kids was so great but do I buy him as a
loan a guy who's like in trouble with
loan sharks and what I mean no I I don't
you know what I mean so you buy more
it's just like that that root for a bull
Underdog where he's gonna take this rag
tag and take them from a bunch of
individuals and make them a team which
is really what he does in both movies
and he's so the other thing I like about
it is like you know he he's the star of
the movie but The Replacements is an
ensemble it's truly an ensemble like
everybody has I can tell you two uh
scenes or gags or jokes with every
character from the team do you know what
I mean and and the other part that
really stood out to me about this movie
aside from the cast which we talked
about a little earlier and and them all
being stars is uh Gene Hackman you know
Gene Hackman is one of those actors who
I've always appreciated he does not
phone things in never it doesn't matter
if it's something is quote unquote
beneath him or whatever you might say
like I I looked at some of the negative
reviews of The Replacements and it was
like what's Gene Hackman doing here you
know whatever but honestly I feel like
he's he's great he's great in this movie
and um so yeah to me that is that is
sort of what makes this better than I
think people give it credit for I think
that's one of the things that
legitimizes this movie Winston is that
you do have you have Jack Warden is the
owner you have Gene Hackman as the coach
reciphons John Favre in Fiverr Orlando
Jones like there's so many great players
in this movie and I love your point
Clark about just like making it feel
like everybody gets their time to shine
my favorite moments in this movie are I
love when the players are at the bar and
they're rallying around each other they
get into a fight they're defending each
other like all of a sudden they become
individuals into a team into a family of
sorts but the other thing I love and you
I think you were at the tail end of this
era and your football watching is having
Pat Summerall and John Madden oh my God
that was amazing during games is great
but having them be the inner monologue
of Shane Falco during that kiss scene at
the bar
that is how I don't know if every guy
does this I certainly do to this day I
have announcers in my head they usually
sound like either out Michael's or Pat
Summerall and John Madden commenting on
everything I'm doing in my life so if
you think I don't have two guys in the
booth when I'm on a date you are sadly
mistake it's it's Bill Simmons
that is the thing I think that's so
amazing for me is like again Orlando
Jones Faison love like for me it's just
like a black youth like for comedy and
like where my mind is going like the
whole like oh this your cop
or like yeah you know you know how you
know how crippled Franklin does baby
girl you know what I mean I'll be out
here in these streets girl and then like
getting thrown out by John Favreau but
then even having those those really
heartwarming moments of uh you know I
can't remember the the character's name
but where he has his knee the injury in
college and he's like all I want is one
touchdown if I get one touchdown before
I get out of here then I consider this a
success right and I think for all of us
that have really like sought after a
dream one way or the other you've had
your highs you've had your lows you just
hope for that one moment that you can
get to that one goal you really want and
so having those little moments in there
is what's so I I think what brings
people back to this movie that's so
interesting you say that because you can
watch any sports movie get inspired but
like the natural is is a touchstone film
for a lot of people but you gotta
remember Roy Hobbs guy had a lot of
talent he was hitting dingers I mean he
had that special bat but also he was
just talented then he got sidetracked so
he's a guy who you knew could do stuff
like that and have that Kirk Gibson
moment but with these guys it's like
this is the closest I've ever felt to
being on an NFL field is I'm like well
these guys could do it I got it there's
got to be a role for me somewhere which
is also a nice entry point as we get
into Hardball here because that's the
next movie sequentially and you talk
about a film where any sports movie is
going to get me somewhat emotional
Hardball does the impossible for Mark
Ellis's cold dead Grinch heart it makes
me root for kids and it makes me so I
don't even want to get to the Heartbreak
yet but it makes me rude for kids
Winston we're talking about the last of
us right before we went to Air and like
did Joel make the right decision with
that and I'm like look I don't know kids
so I think that's an indefensible
decision but you put this movie on our
table is it the kids that get you is it
Keanu is it the relationships it's it is
definitely the kids it does not mean
that you don't appreciate uh what Keanu
is bringing to the table but it is
definitely the kids it is the the back
and forth but it's also just for context
of where we're at at this point this
comes out September 14 2001. this is
three days after September 11th that
this still drops and the soundtrack
dropped on September 11th yes it did and
so two one it didn't like really gross
that much of a profit I mean 44 million
over 32 like that's not that's
technically if we're still falling under
that you got to do
double your budget to get to marketing
then you technically didn't cover but
for it to do any sort of money at that
point where a lot of people were scared
in that moment similar to the pandemic
where you're just at home people were
not they certainly weren't traveling but
they weren't going to the movies but
some people did because they needed a
distraction
um for it to do even that well for
anybody to see this movie absolutely is
an achievement absolutely but for it to
become such a cult classic like I I will
never forget the whole like big papa
like dancing to get the kid to like to
be able to pitch and whatnot
foreign
[Music]
yes he does and so I so even that I'm
like oh my goodness like you know he's
been out here doing it for a minute and
in my mind I'm thinking oh the wire was
the first thing he did and it's not it
was this
um or one of the first things he did
um I know we're you know a lot of people
in the black community are tired of like
white savior movies and this idea of
like I'm gonna come in the hood I'm
gonna fix you and blah blah blah blah
but there is something about this one in
particular
um and you see this with the kids where
everyone's like who is this corny white
man he's like whatever and you see Kofi
is running his mouth Non-Stop and he's
like man you trash dog why why are you
so fat and why are you this or whatever
and so Keanu Connor hits a ball right at
him he goes hey why'd you duck you
scared and they were like oh okay Coach
got something here and that was what
Keanu was able to do it's that Michelle
Pfeiffer Dangerous Minds moments where
it's like you guys really want to push
me dude do you know where I come from
what is this yeah and yeah I mean you
can't a race he's got he's he's race but
he can certainly pass as a as a white
guy like me absolutely when you when you
look at this movie and I'll give credit
for this and actually one of my favorite
reviewers she's killing me right now uh
the Claudia Pew from USA Today she said
Hardball has more going for it than the
Dismal Replacements
comparison and I was like okay I want on
the show Claudia you're my favorite
movie reviewer but you're just just
twisting that knife uh for me Clark I
was and I you know how much I love The
Replacements and and with your movie
knock knock I think that Hardball has
the best case for like seriously why in
the hell are you rotten on the Tomato
Meter because I can understand people
watching The Replacements and just
thinking it's ridiculous and it's too
comedic or whatever they might have I
can say it as Cinema I I understand some
of your gripes with Hardball I'm sort of
dumbfounded the only thing I can think
of is like it just made critics so sad
at the end because we lose somebody that
we didn't expect to and that's why they
graded it lower yeah I mean I think well
this is this is a real uh combination of
a lot of things like so Brian Robbins
directing who is responsible for most of
us 90s kids childhoods you know of you
know Keenan and Kel and all that and
um and so this movie here's what I would
say this movie doesn't fit neatly into a
heartwarming white savior movie there's
some really upsetting stuff in this
movie and not just the thing at the end
which I'm sure we'll get to I watching
watching these kids get beat up sucks
like I really didn't I didn't care for
it you know what I'm gonna go on record
and saying I did not enjoy watching
these children be beat up it's not great
for me it always hurts my goodness and
that's one of the reasons why I hate
that I'm rooting for kids in a movie but
it's like seeing kids get bullied I
cannot stand it and and I think that
maybe some of this might have been too
real like do you know what I'm saying
like like this doesn't fit neatly into
what we've come to expect from these
movies especially uh Sports movies but
you know and so and so maybe it was a
little like I don't I don't know what
they were thinking but maybe they're
saying I mean you're just tugging on
that utter of emotion a little too much
maybe you're overdoing it but but even
that it just feels like I mean it does
feel like a more real holistic sports
movie as a result agreed agreed so I I
certainly don't certainly don't share
that criticism but in terms of why they
did critics not Rally around this
um maybe that's a solution I don't know
it's funny because I was just trying to
I was looking at some of these right now
and one of the ones uh that I can sort
of agree with from Eric child is uh a
Childress excuse me who was saying that
they kind of pulled the punches a little
bit because it was PG-13
um
and I sort of agree there are moments
obviously that I think you you still hit
on so Jefferson getting jumped for his
bag uh the you know the sitting on the
floor you know for gunshots and then
obviously the the very sad ending but
yeah you you kind of only touch on it a
little bit I understand that Keanu is
the main character here but I always
found myself way more interested as to
what's going on in these children's
lives totally um so whenever we went to
his bookie situation I'm like okay and
like we saw Emilio do this already you
know with the Mighty Ducks I don't I
know I don't care it's like we now that
we met the team yeah I don't care about
coaches individual problems as much I
don't care about his DUI I don't care
about his game but let's just get back
to the diamond yes absolutely and so
that's that that is the one thing that I
will say is I do genuinely wish I I
would have
um one of my other favorite sports
movies Coach Carter uh with Samuel
Jackson also directed by Brian Robbins
really yeah
[Laughter]
he also directed Good Burger for uh yeah
um but the fact that we have moments
that when
um uh cannot remember the actor's name
but he is on um law order uh organized
crime right now
um he he plays the the Latino uh high
schooler that like quits the team and
then kind of his cousin gets murdered
and then he just begs to come back right
it's the idea that we actually followed
when he left the team and what that
meant we saw Jamal for half a second it
was like Jamal and he's like
and just puts his head down I would have
liked to have seen a situation where
maybe Jamal was forced to shoot along
with them and maybe he's the reason that
gbaby unfortunately passes or maybe he
ends up like catching a case of some
sort not because I want to see bad
things happen but if we're really going
to go there if we're really going to
touch it do it I will say when when
g-baby is killed
um I will say for me it felt like it
kind of came out of nowhere because we
weren't following that story closely
enough right it felt like two movies
kind of being put into one and and so
maybe you know and and it it shocked me
I mean I feel like I had seen The
Replacements on TV growing up and maybe
I had seen a scene or two of Hardball uh
on TV but I did not I did not remember
this ending if I had and so but but I
was like I I we keep like uh dipping our
toe into the real lives of these kids
and then when this very extreme outcome
happens I was like whoa okay uh it was
very it was very sad and the veneer of
hard Bond I think this is why it throws
people for a loop even like when I'm
re-watching it you know it's it for very
different reasons it's like another
sports movie Tin Cup where nobody's
dying at the end of 10 cup but you just
watch uh Kevin Costner's character Roy
McAfee he just keeps dropping dropping
the ball and trying to hit it over the
water and you're like dude you're
blowing your shot of winning the US Open
I can't watch that scene so I love Tin
Cup up to that moment then I just go
walk the dog same thing with Hardball
but Hardball had that veneer of Bad News
Bears yes the sand wad of like these
baseball movies that we just love and oh
that coach isn't mismatched with these
players how is this all gonna work and
then it there are some some genuine
comedic wacky moments and it's funny but
then there's also just like we were not
expecting The Sandlot and Bad News Bears
did not train us for the drama in this
movie you know what this feels like
because I had mentioned the Mighty Ducks
earlier this feels like if the Mighty
Ducks is The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
hard ball is Bel Air it's a it's a it's
a nah I'm gonna show you what's real
like what what this is Rich dude comes
in or in this case not that rich but
just like he's in his own little white
world and he's coming down into it and
this movie will always have a special
place in my heart especially because we
also got the the the rap super group The
Little Rascals that consisted of Lil
Wayne Lil Zane Lil Bow Wow at the time
and oh my God and little Sammy uh there
you go that track I had on repeat I
remember that was one of the first songs
I don't know if I can admit to crimes in
2001 but that that's one of the first
songs illegally downloaded off Kazaa Oh
no just listening
the Metallica van shows up nope they're
just blasting rides
it's like it's not even your band well
ours relaxed
piracy is not a victimless crime it's
all it's it's all coming out now
everybody just airing their dirty
laundry here on Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
and as we transition into to Clark's
movie knock knock which is the most
recent of the films it also has the
distinct pleasure of being the lowest
rate on the Tomato Meter of the four
because replacement's 41 as is Hardball
knock knock a little over 37 percent my
opening question to you Clark is I know
you will you love horror movies and
you're one of these people that can
vacillate between your fun jump scare
horror movies your your slashers where
we're cracking jokes and your elevated
horror so to speak I'm curious what the
audience was expecting in your work
coming in is because the audience score
unlike Hardball in The Replacements
where the audience score jumps up to
Fresh here 37 rotten for the Tomato
Meter 19 for the audience score what did
both the critics and the audience Miss
with this movie this is a great question
and I think this is a big part of why
knock knock is not as well received as
it could be the idea that it was sold on
Eli Roth's name Eli Roth of course
co-writer and the director of of this
movie best known arguably for the
Hostile series and and Cabin Fever
before that and I think that Eli you
know Eliza now uh with with more time
has has directed kids movies and he's
directed he's directed a plethora of
different kinds of films but at this
point if you're selling this as a home
invasion movie from Eli Ross
exactly and starring Keanu Reeves right
so um you know I think the expectations
is a big part of of these of these
scores when when I watch this movie I'm
like oh yes Eli is and you know you do
any reading into it you see that he is
uh remaking an exploitation film from
the 70s but this is Eli doing his uh his
European cinema this is him doing a a
trashy exploitation movie a sex movie
like this is a very specific type of
film that if you don't know that going
in you probably are like I'm sorry what
and I also think that to the point about
the acting you know there is a stylized
type of acting and I think that this is
for me keanu's like something that's so
interesting not just about Keanu Reeves
but about movie stars when we know movie
stars we know what they should be doing
and how they should be acting and I
think that this is just a wild
performance from everyone involved but
everybody commits and for me that is the
thing that I always appreciate and I
always enjoy I won't quote from it but
there is a monologue at the end of this
movie where Keanu Recaps the events that
we have just witnessed thank you for
that he is tied to a chair and it is I
mean it is it is something it is so but
to me that is not an accident you know
what I'm saying like to me Keanu Reeves
is a is a very talented performer this
is just something a little outside the
norm for him and I think that style of
performance is intentional that would be
my argument that's what I was going to
ask you is like Winston I watched this
movie and it just seems so like I'm
prepared for like a thriller along the
lines of something like the strangers
right where there's a knock and you're
like what the hell is happening and it's
a home invasion kind of movie like you
said plus this movie had the I say
displeasure coming out in 2015 a year
after Keanu had his Resurgence John Wick
he's got the long hair it's raining in
those movies there's a crap ton of
violence so we're like oh what's he
gonna do now as a bad guy and then you
watch it there's a lot of Camp to this
too and it feels like to hear Clark talk
about it feels like that was intentional
but you can only say that if it's really
hitting home and sometimes it just
doesn't work even if that's what you're
expecting it's so what my issue is is
because I don't have a problem with any
sort of committing it's just that
totally it shifts so much and not in a
balanced way way that I can't ever
anchor so we kind of start off with him
and like oh the monster's gonna get you
and like come on baby like that acting
in that moment with the family I was
like this isn't that good to start off
then Louise shows up I'm like okay he's
he is clearly in a realistic World
whereas it feels like the family's like
kind of we're in a movie bye dad
and then the girls show up and that also
feels very grounded where it's just like
Hey we're stranded and you can see that
the the grift is coming one way or the
other and then like they're kind of
turning the the sex appeal on and all
that all of that feels very like this is
a real thing that's going on all dude
don't do it don't do it and then the
minute we actually get into the girls
going a little bit
that was almost 2-0 to 100 of like he
wakes up and the entire kitchen is
destroyed I was like
hmm I'm not saying that you don't go for
it but like I just it was it was why are
we already doing 200 on the freeway I
was asleep for four hours right and
we're doing two hot whoa so just the
tone of the movies jostling you around
like you're like like you're in a 4dx
theater and you weren't prepared for
like all this just back and forth and
and then to that point I get what
Clark's saying is that actors should
want to try and Branch out um they
should want to try different things
different states of emotions different
states of being but like when keanu's
having his full oh hell yeah like I
don't believe that I feel like they're
like more Keanu more more more and I'm
like less less I don't I don't know
this is I will say for because with the
Eli Roth of it all you know with the
excess like in Hostel or Cabin Fever we
are just like over the top right and so
yes to your point we he more instead of
more blood it's more screaming
and so again like a a choice right and I
totally understand a choice that does
not work for everybody but it it is the
type of thing that I love is sandbox I
love seeing Eli plan I also wanted to
mention Eli uh grew one of his parents
is an artist he grew up in the art world
and so I love the idea of there's that
little bit of satire that camp around
the art world and things like that like
these are but again I I totally
understand if it is not effective for
another I want to ask you a cartoon
about because you mentioned Eli Roth and
having his name attached was a big deal
still is a big deal for movies and
getting a film made and distributed you
have him in Keanu Reeves this movie
premiered at Sundance in early 2015
immediately gets picked up by Lions game
because they're like oh it's it's got
Keanu super hot right now it's got Eli
Roth but it feels to me like the
marketing for this movie may have been a
mislead as to what it was along the
lines of something like when we saw M
Night shyamalan's name in the village
and we're expecting this is a Creature
Feature turned out to be something very
different which left me cold as a viewer
at the time but now I watch The Village
I'm like this is a great movie because
now I don't have that set of
expectations it comes at night another
horror movie where it's like feels like
it's setting you up for one thing it
ended up being something else so it's
it's an increasingly crowded space with
how many films are made so you feel like
you have to stand out if if your wives
get like okay we we just bought this
thing we gotta make it stand out we got
to make a trail he's gonna sell this
movie put butts and seats it ended up
costing I think two and a half million
hours and the worldwide gross was like
five and a half million dollars but is
that part of I guess your argument where
it's like this movie was not marketed so
we already had a different set of
expectations in our head than what we
should have had given what the movie
actually wanted to be I would agree with
that I would also say this is the the
first time I saw on a day armis and I
actually I know you did not care for the
performance I love her in this movie
She's wild and um and and that's the
thing like so so then I started thinking
out deep water with her and Ben Affleck
that is this is I believe that's Adrian
Lynn so it's this like real throwback
erotic Thriller in the vein of like
Basic Instinct and Fatal Attraction or
whatever so it's different and I would
argue deep water didn't actually go
there far enough but that was another
one where I was looking at the acting
like Ben Affleck is so wild it's like
it's just these performances if you're
if you transport them back to 1992
you're like oh this would be a different
story but uh I bring it up because
um uh I think that if this movie came
out now maybe and it was and we were
having the conversation of like this is
very much in the vein of your you know
exploitation and and it is a sex movie
and it's oh my gosh y'all Ana de armas
it just daddy daddy and then she did
well with that and then in blonde though
she's just nominated for an Oscar and
she's calling everybody daddy again and
I'm like oh my gosh
Oh Daddy yes oh my God it's just I get a
it's a hoot
you know Clark it's one of you mentioned
that because about about uh if we did it
again this year the one thing that kept
ringing into my head honestly is uh are
either of you Black Mirror fans oh yeah
oh yeah this Shut Up and Dance if you
remember that one that's where the kid
gets this anonymous text go to this spot
right now or I'm gonna send the photos
of the the video of you uh to little
kids and then as you go through you find
out all these people that are being
forced to do it also that exploitation
to kind of see that there where like
sure there were little moments of comedy
about them arguing who was gonna rob the
bank and who was going to drive the car
and things like that it was so grounded
in such a ridiculous premise that I was
like oh my God the entire time whereas
this when at points I'm seeing Keanu
from speed after the stairs blow up and
he's like
I was like bro bring me back what are
you doing that and I I honestly did like
Anna's uh perform it could be uneven
just based off overall what's going on
but like lorenza sometimes she was just
too much for me and I and I didn't
necessarily believe what was happening
and I don't know if that's the writing I
don't know if that's the acting I'm not
sure where we connect those dots but I
understand why Keanu would have been
attracted to this project if done
properly this is the type of premise
that you you eat up this is the type of
thing that could get you an Oscar nod at
some point I mean look at what parasite
did but like I just don't think it was
executed very well I feel like this
movie could limp into close to Fresh
territory but I don't I don't think I
can get it to Fresh uh Winston has a
downgraded on his Demand on his personal
I'm just gonna say uh interesting choice
of words
or the whipping to Fresh
um so that is knock knock and but Clark
I also wanted to ask you because you
have this new movie it's been a big
theatrical release malum tell us a
little bit about that and how you know
you look at a movie like knock knock and
you want the audience to understand and
what they're going in for yes a great
great Point um so I have I am in a movie
called mallam it is in theaters on March
31st it's a small uh well it's a it's an
indie horror movie from a new production
company called Welcome villain and uh
when I say it's in theaters it's like
not day and day not doing like a weekend
it's it's gonna be in theater so got us
a run go check it out you know horror is
having especially Indie small Horrors
having such an interesting time at the
box office right now with skinamarink
and with you know uh terrifier 2 and
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey like it
sounds funny but all these movies are
made crossing the million dollar line
because they're actually getting a
theatrical release so um malum is a
reimagining of an independent film
directed by Anthony De blasi called the
last shift
um a lot of people have seen it maybe on
streaming services came out I believe in
2015. and Anthony made that money for
that movie for very little money and
with what he was able to do I love the
last shift but like knowing how hard he
worked and what little resources he had
it's amazing how effective that movie is
and so when welcome villain was starting
up they went back to Anthony and they
said hey would you ever want to revisit
the last shift with more resources and
more money and and he so he took them up
on that opportunity which is like such
an amazing thing for a filmmaker and so
he has been describing it as it's not a
reboot it's not a remake it is a
reimagining they are separate movies but
you will see a similar through line here
and one of the things that Anthony was
able to do was really expand on the cult
so the premise is a a rookie police
officer her father it was a police
officer as well he was killed uh at this
police station when a cult that he had
stopped came for him and so her first
shift as a police officer is to guard
the abandoned police station that he
died in overnight oh that's not going to
be here and then you know what it
doesn't go well there's no spoilers it's
gonna go so smooth I think so yeah see I
already know if it had been a black boy
and his daddy had been killed like
they'd be like well Dad I'm sorry son I
I gotta get out of here
is that some fire I gotta go okay
yeah so I play one of the cult members
and that is something that is different
from uh from the first film to this
reimagining is we really get to spend
more time with the cult and with this
mythology
um the Russells who have done the
Practical effects for the new Hellraiser
movie and and so many awesome practical
effects did our creature effects as well
so it is uh it is a wild ride it's so
exciting to have this coming out and
have a theatrical run where folks out
there because I've always said this
about horror movies I think even more so
than comedies I think horror movies are
the flicks that you want to see in a
theater opening weekend with a packed
house because just the way people are
reacting yeah this is a movie for horror
fans which is really fun and I hope they
get out cannot wait as of this taping
mere weeks away from malm opening in
theaters March 31st I want to end this
movie talk segment quickly by reminding
everybody that Keanu Reeves as Clark
highlighted we many of us first met him
in the Bill and Ted movies happy to say
that both Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure and Bill and Ted the most
recent one that came out is fresh on the
Tomato Meter wow intense Bogus Journey
56 just missing that Fresh Mark I think
that's a fresh movie I think that movie
might have been ahead of its time and it
was a sequel that was made around the
time we got like Batman Returns where
it's like sequels and they went in
rapidly different directions than the
audience might have expected how'd the
audience do on it though 56 for the
audience
[Music]
that movie's fresh alone for death and
his performance it's just so good damn
right all right let's go to the big
finish Brian hit the music
foreign
talking about Keanu Reeves you know his
career to me seemed to mirror in in some
ways Matthew McConaughey because we knew
him as this Vibe more than like an actor
but McConaughey had uh to uh A Time to
Kill come out after we kind of met him
in days confused and he was great in A
Time to Kill so I think we gave him more
credibility as like an actor an a-lister
but then he ran and did a bunch of
rom-coms and had to sort of have his own
reconnaissance we had the Keanu Sons
because I think that people just didn't
give him the credit he deserved even
though he'd done movies like The Matrix
and speed and stuff like that so uh
we're bathing in it right now and John
Wick 4 coming in theaters in a matter of
weeks as well and I've seen it it's
definitely worth your time in a movie
theater uh thank you so much to my
special guest join us today Winston a
marshall where can all the fans out
there find you and your love for the
Dallas Cowboys who checks notes did lose
on Monday Night Football in 1987 to
replacement players gonna keep doing
this by Washington why do I keep coming
on the show
um you can find me at this swaggy
blurred I am doing all the things uh
across all the platforms man so YouTube
Tick Tock Twitter if you want to see me
you know a couple of people trying to
comfort a queen Angela Bassett I'm not
here for it I'm not
um but all across that stuff I got a lot
of Comedy stuff going on there a lot of
sketches and whatnot but and then also
some great review shows and I'm also as
uh Mark mentioned on capes and cows with
Christian harloff over on his channel as
well so come check that out come say
what's up uh got some fun stuff coming
up in the next couple of weeks that I am
very excited I don't want to ruin any
surprises though there you go so you
could kind of say what capes and cows
speak you could say uh the sand lot is
like Batman and Robin and then Hardball
is like the Batman with Robert Pattinson
where it's like the same kind of sport
but very very different very different
very different very different Vibes uh
Clark wolf thank you so much for joining
us it's my fault that we took so long to
have you on the show but I'm glad we
timed it well because you got the short
a shiny example coming out and then
malam in theaters March 31st indeed you
are correct and can I just say we just
did this entire show I just noticed that
camera my camera
[Laughter]
anyway thank you for having me and this
was very fun uh yes malam is in theaters
on March 31st and you can find me on
Instagram and Twitter at Clark wolf
Clark with any wolf of the name all
right I guess this was the dress
rehearsal so now everybody knows where
the cameras are we're gonna knock this
whole episode out again uh I am merely
Mark Ellis for upcoming stand-up dates
and go to markels.live for the whole
gang here at Rotten Tomatoes and my
beloved co-host Jacqueline Coley I am
merely Mark Ellis saying chicks dig
scars
[Music]
thank you